are you cool talking about sobriety yeah
man absolutely curious on what your drug
of choice was because i read that you
were doing math at some time
well when i was a kid yeah i was uh when
i was a kid i was a speed freak um i did
coke it did math i did all that stuff um
but as i got i quit all that when i was
a teenager because i i od twice when i
was a teenager before i was 16. yeah
um to quit all that i got older i got
more into booze
honestly because it was just easy you
know and my personality is such that
i never drank to chill i just drank to
just
get [ __ ] up you know so
it was you know it was easy
to just stay medicated for you know
especially doing what i do
and to just you know just continue that
and i just i found myself becoming
very very unavailable in my own life man
you know and
when you're a father uh you know at the
time i was
married a long time ago
and i just kind of i just decided i was
like man i got to figure this out or
you know this is going to go
a direction that i don't want it to go
you know so
it took a long time to kind of figure
out who i was and be comfortable with it
again man you know
so when you guys were getting [ __ ] up
what was on the slipknot ryder when you
guys were just going there [ __ ]
oh
dude
i don't even know if this was on the
rider but we just had it at all times we
had at least
nine bottles of jack at any at every
show
um we had crown royal we had jaeger
there was like some some people drank
vodka
um
guys would have
uh guys would have drugs brought
which i never saw because that by that
time i was just a you know just an
alcoholic
um
yeah man there was i mean there was a a
lot of crazy [ __ ]
and so you guys would go on
waking up on a pool table like in just
you know just waking i'm like
in a bar like i was like i was like how
the [ __ ] did i get
here i was miles away from the gig i
have no idea
but how about how about the story about
you waking up in a [ __ ] trash can
like you're a [ __ ] dumpster that's
what i was wearing right
yeah that was after i'd od yeah i uh
and i think what happened was i
i the last thing i remember i was at a
party this is when i was living in
waterloo iowa i was at a party
uh blacked out we were all just kind of
doing you know just whatever was there
i think
i
like my heart stopped something happened
and my friend well my friends
threw me away
i think that's what yeah i think that's
what happened that's the kind of city
that that city is anyway but like when
you wake when you come to
i was covered in my own blood um i kind
of i pulled myself out of the dumpster i
had no shoes on
and i was like strike like because
there's that moment where you're like
you don't really remember how you got
there
and i had to walk dude i was 12 miles
away from my house
geez
yeah i walked
all the way back
and as i was walking i was like it was
starting to kind of come to me
and
within a week i moved out of waterloo i
moved to live with my grandmother in des
moines which
and then there you were in the morning
did you ever see those guys after that
or talked to them about it
no i didn't want it
yeah at that point i was like well if
i'm dead to them they're dead to me yeah
jesus christ yeah it's pretty heavy but
then what about like that little
possibility that like there was some
perfectly
good explanation for why you ended up in
the trash can and they didn't throw you
away mean that's a good question dude i
this day i was like
i just kind of was just like you know
what i should probably shouldn't ever go
back to that life again you know i kind
of cut it off but that's a good question
it never even occurred to me but maybe
there was another
just like a perfectly innocent i mean
there's not a lot of perfectly innocent
or good reasons to end up like it was it
a trash can or a dumpster
that was a dumpster
yeah it was a dumpster yeah that puts
you right up there with nikki sixx he
the same thing happened to him in uh
london in
uh
february of 1986.
what happened he got he [ __ ] woke up
in a dumpster he went and [ __ ] scored
[ __ ] odd and they're like [ __ ] this
dude the guy's dead they're almost down
the same deal oh [ __ ]
yeah oh man and then and then he wrote a
tune about it called [ __ ] uh dancing
on glass
glass yeah some of the girls girls girls
out there yeah dude [ __ ] i love motley
crue man and then
how long did how long did it take you to
get sober until after that point
well he said that was when he was a
teenager so
now 11 years ago
yeah 2010. oh [ __ ] so you got sober
right after paul gray died
is that right i got yeah yeah i um
because i had i had quit drinking and i
started again
and then when paulie died
i uh
it was kind of it was kind of weird like
i was drinking
to
kind of
deaden
the pain
but then physically it was hurting me
and it which made it really easy for me
to quit you know so i i i quit about a
month after he passed
man yeah i'm sorry who's paul gray he's
one of the founding members of slipknot
he was a bassist and
by all accounts the most down-to-earth
guy
uh
nicest guy didn't consider himself a
rock star but
you know ultimately succumbed to the
substance abuse and died of an overdose
man what was that last day of
what was that last day of using like for
you it was
it was weird man like i was kind of
heading that way anyway and
i was on the uh
i was on this uh
tour with stone sour
and
we were at this kind of like after show
party
and
i'm not a beer drinker but i was
that's all they had so i was just kind
of like tipping a couple of becks back
and i woke up the next day and i felt
awful like just and i i had
two beers and i i had a hangover that
felt like i drank three bottles of
whiskey
and it just
for some reason it that was like
the moment where i was just like you
know what i think this is it this is it
this is it i'm not getting anything out
of this anymore like there's no pleasure
in it there's no
party in it there's nothing that i'm
getting from it except pain i was like
why do i keep doing this so
and that between that and the fact that
i just lost my brother to a you know who
who he fought it his whole life
like he
would he would go to he would go to
treatment he would come out and he would
fight with his entire will and it was
just too much he just kept going back to
it man and
but that that was it for me i was just
like i just i can't i can't do it so did
that did it start with you going going
into treatment or you just did it on
your own no i just i yeah i dried dried
it i dropped it
i've always done that i've actually
that's how i quit drugs as well i just
you know you deal with the dts for a few
days and then that's it i did the same
thing with smoking i just i just there's
something in my brain that just goes
you're done and i just so quick so you
did the dry thing for for a while and
then were you like wow dude like maybe i
should get some support and and join the
fellowship that's great
i'm not i'm not in the program
but all of my friends are in the program
so
when i hang out with my friends it's
almost like i'm in a de facto meeting to
begin with and when we talk
yeah so it's so it's weird and they all
have known
everything that i'd gone through
everything they were all friends with
all my friends and
it's it's almost like being in the
program but not you know right i mean
my uh
sort of take on it is that i mean for me
i just don't even want to experiment
with what happens in me trying to stay
sober by myself because i'm a [ __ ]
dead duck
but the way that you described having
been on you know meth and coke and just
put it down and then like only alcohol
you know like
some people can do it and evidently
you're somebody you can pull it so
[ __ ] right on it's a weird switch man
it's thank you i mean
and i'd still to this day don't know why
but it's also i've i've experienced that
in my life as well like
with
relationships with people who
were clearly not good for me i just
once i kind of figured that out i'm just
like you're done and i cut people out
you know i just i've never overstayed my
welcome with anyone well i can't say
i've been one but i was married to her
and that doesn't count
and uh
but yeah i mean it's just it's weird man
i uh
i guess it's the blessing
um
i wish it would have you know kind of
kicked in quicker but at the same time i
wouldn't be where i'm at now if i have
gone through
what i have you know so i never look at
anything with regret i always look at it
from the standpoint of i'm going to
learn from everything that i've been
through and i'm going to write about it
and if people
if it helps anybody then so be it can i
just tell you how [ __ ] up my new tour
is it's completely multimedia
legitimately x-rated there's legal
waivers all over the venue because i'm
actually worried about getting sued and
i don't give a [ __ ] man because it's
gnarly and it's all the stuff i wasn't
allowed to do on jackass so get to my
[ __ ] website stevo.com and get your
tickets man especially with this movie
coming out dude they're all gonna sell
dude so hurry up while you can get seats